MonkaW
Easy.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Alter, Windows, warum?
Warum hat Windows einfach random einen Sound umgestellt?
So, ich bin am Start.
Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Ich hab, ich mein, überleg mal, ich hab nix gemacht seit gestern, ne?
Gestern ging der Sound noch.
Heute Morgen Rechner geschnitten, Sound geht nicht mehr.
Mal gucken.
Übrigens, das, was der Chat gestern gesagt hat, ist falsch gewesen.
Der Chat hat ja gesagt, das hier schaltet sich automatisch wieder ein.
Macht es aber nicht.
Muss doch über die Registry wieder einschalten.
Oder ich lasse den Scheiß einfach aus.
Weil ganz ehrlich, das hat mich gestern so abgefuckt.
Dass ich meine eigene Anwendung nicht mal ausführen konnte, weil Microsoft der Meinung war, die ist nicht gesigned.
So, jetzt.
Übrigens, Chat, ich habe rausgekriegt, warum das mit der Netzwerkkarte gestern nicht funktioniert hat.
Kann ich euch zeigen.
Ich habe gestern Abend noch ein bisschen gebastelt, aber ich habe PXE-Boot nicht hinbekommen
Ich habe sogar IPXE geflasht auf die Netzwerkkarte, das hat mich hingehauen
Ich weiß jetzt, warum das nicht funktioniert hat mit der Netzwerkkarte
Dass man da von Linux aus irgendwelche Settings setzt
Das liegt daran, ich muss euch das gar nicht zeigen, ich kann es euch einfach sagen
Das liegt daran, dass diese Netzwerkkarte
Wohl sehr wenig
Speicher hat oder so
Zumindest hat es ja Support geschrieben
Und die ist nicht erlaubt dynamisch
Sachen zu setzen
Deswegen gibt es so eine kryptische Fehlermeldung
Nö nö, ich bin mir eben was aufgestanden
Boah, naja doch, ist schon eine halbe Stunde her
Nö nö nö
Wahrscheinlich habe ich gestern zu viel gelabert und mich zu viel aufgeregt
Also das lag nicht an uns, dass wir irgendwas verkehrt gemacht haben
Sondern
Das liegt an der Netzwerkkarte
selbst. Aber
letztendlich mal ohne Mist, also dadurch,
dass das Ding nicht PXE booten kann,
richtig, und
das so ein Krampf ist, ich kaufe
mir einfach eine andere Netzwerkkarte.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ich gehe jetzt einfach mal
auf Ebay, also nicht jetzt im
Stream, sondern sonst, und dann kaufe ich mir irgendwie
eine Intel X,
irgendwie so eine oder sowas, ja.
Irgendwie so ein Ding.
Und wann gibt es die eigentlich auch als Singleport?
WTF ist das?
Warum hatten sie ein Loch?
Ja, irgendwie so ein Teil oder so
Die Dinger sind ja nicht sonderlich teuer
Kann man sich bei Amazon kaufen
Oder aber
Und das ist wahrscheinlich das, was ich eher machen werde
Ich benutze einfach
Mein Onboard 10 Gig
auch wenn der kein
SEO-Vau kann, scheiß drauf, ich meine
ich brauche das ja wahrscheinlich eh noch nicht mal in der
VM, oder vielleicht
mache ich doch Open Media Vault drauf und es geht
über die normale Bridge in Software, weil ich meine
der Rechner hat ja genug Power, also
da machen wir heute Mittag wahrscheinlich weiter
das stellt's
muss jetzt Proxmox installiert werden und mal gucken
wie schnell das Ding über das Netzwerk ist
Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Was für eine Netzwerkkarte habe ich eigentlich hier in meinem...
Was ist denn das?
Akadie Connect.
Was für eine Netzwerkkarte habe ich denn hier eigentlich in meiner Windows-Kiste drin?
Okay.
Jetzt guck mal mal, wie findet man das raus über die Windows-Settings?
Soll ich normalerweise durch den Gerätemanager oder so gucken?
Oder die alte Systemsteuerung?
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir mal, wie schnell wir das finden.
Network.
Ethernet Settings
Ach stimmt, das zeigt ja die falsche an
Das zeigt ja immer die falsche Netzwerkkarte an
Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie es geht, Leute
Network Advanced
Advanced Network Settings
Ey, ist das so dumm?
Hier, guck mal, ich hab hier auch einen von diesen Schrott-Netzwerkkarten drin
Immer im Rechner
Melanox X3
X3.
10 Gig.
Vielleicht sollte ich für meinen Rechner, für meinen Main-Rechner auch mal eine gescheite neue kaufen.
Wobei, unter Windows, ne, das funzt ja hier, funzt ja hier ordentlich.
Warum, warum sollte ich eine neue kaufen, man?
Scheiß drauf.
Geht.
Und die geht recht gut.
Kann man hier eigentlich Bluetooth an- und ausschalten?
die auch mal flaschen auf windows nee warum sollte ich die flaschen die funktioniert ja gut ich
wollte die ja eigentlich nur flaschen um es an zu machen und um die gut einzuschalten aber wie
gesagt von zwei richtig ist auch egal ganz ehrlich wir testen heute mal die on board netzwerkkarte
Wahrscheinlich ist die gar nicht so schlecht.
Einzig dumme ist, dass die kein SRE-WOW-Support hat.
Das heißt, wir brauchen ein bisschen mehr CPU-Last und haben vielleicht ein bisschen weniger Performance,
netzwerktechnisch in einer VM.
Aber ansonsten, ich meine, der Rechner hat ja genug Power.
Ansonsten funktioniert es wahrscheinlich.
Sekunde, Leute, ich muss noch kurz meine Tastatur rausziehen und wieder reinstecken,
weil mein RGB, jetzt stimmt mein RGB.
Wichtig. RGB muss stimmen.
Ohne RGB geht das nicht.
So, machen wir mal hier Systemupdates.
Zack.
Yes.
Excellent.
Ja, Packet Tracer will immer nicht.
Das stört mich nicht.
Ich habe ja einen installiert.
Und jetzt machen wir noch Jetplane-Updates.
Falls es welche gibt.
Gibt es.
Goland und PyCharm.
chat warum wird es downgrade von 32 ach nee moment 321
ok update
für die experience ich hatte gestern genug netzwerk karten experience das reicht mir
erste war. Ey, Leute, wir haben gestern
für alle, die nicht am Start waren,
wir haben gestern
Wubblos, Biografie,
Herkunft, Freundin, Frau,
Karriere und so weiter.
Ach ja.
Okay.
Die Seite will ich nicht aufmachen unter Windows.
Das ist irgend so eine
Gbait-Seite.
Die machen wir hier unter Linux
in einem anonymen Tab auf.
Also jetzt gucken wir mal.
Die Seite
für den Schrott ist sogar nicht mehr online.
So.
Und jetzt kriege ich Werbung.
Wir haben gestern
5 Stunden
versucht eine Netzwerkkarte
zu flashen.
Also wir haben es ja auch geschafft zu flashen
Wir wollten, also ich wollte PXE-Boot
Aktivieren und dann wollten wir noch gucken
Dass erst mal IOV aktiviert ist
Und es sind 5,5 Stunden fast
Oder sagen wir mal 5 Stunden, ich habe ein bisschen geschwätzt am Anfang
Und euch ein paar Werkzeuge gezeigt, aber
Hier, 5 Stunden haben wir bei dem Kram rumgemacht
Das war einer der längsten Streams in letzter Zeit
Und wirklich viel gebracht
Außer dass wir was gelernt haben, hat es nicht
Aber das ist ja auch schon mal was
Hehehe
Also gestern hat ja auch vieles nicht funktioniert
Ich habe ein NAS mit einer RTL 8127.
Haben wir gestern auch ausprobiert im Stream.
Facegesicht, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscription.
Da habe ich eine in meinem NAS drin.
also das nass hat eine also das eine nass ich habe ja mittlerweile hier drei stück
stehen zum ausprobieren ich habe wieder richtig hardcore den hier gemacht
der anfang weil ich mich so aufgeregt habe ja geil
was seine netzwerk konflikt zerschossen ja da bin ich mal gespannt ich habe mir
proxmox und nicht so viel erfahrung also ich habe netzwerk netzwerk 10 gig
netzwerk haben in dem das ist nur on board 10 gig netzwerkkarte das ist so
eine hier genau so eine video schreibst dann ist noch eine 5 gig on board
netzwerkkarte drin das ist eine rtl 8125 glaube ich bin ich mir jetzt ganz sicher
mal kurz gucken
Da ist
Realtek.
Das findet man natürlich nicht.
Gibt es hier...
Seht ihr hier irgendwo...
Boah, die Seite, Mann.
Kurz...
Meine Auge.
Seht ihr hier irgendwie sowas wie
Datasheet oder sowas?
Gibt es hier sowas vielleicht?
Außer ganz viel Gelaber.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Das ist der 10-Gig.
RTL 8127
und jetzt müssen wir mal gucken
steht da irgendwas
ah ne ok
5 Gig
dann ist wahrscheinlich der 8125
der 2,5 Gig
vermutlich
ja und dann
habe ich noch eine alte
ähm
dann habe ich noch eine alte Melanox
Connect X3
drin. Und die haben wir gestern
versucht zu flashen. Und das war abartig.
Aber die ist ja auch, die ist über 10 Jahre
alt, die Karte.
Wieso gibt es beides?
Weil
das hier das N5
Pro ist und das das
N5 Air. Warum auch immer
AI? Keine Ahnung.
Und das N5 Pro
hat eine Aquantik.
Find ich jetzt blöd? Wo ist es denn?
Hanna Aquantik.
Netzwerkkarte drinne.
Und die 8126.
Und das andere hat die...
Das liegt daran, weil die Netzwerkkarte ein paar Cent billiger ist als die hier.
Mir persönlich wäre die lieber, weil ich...
Mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir, die ist ein bisschen älter und der Linux-Support ein bisschen besser.
Als die hier.
Weil die hier gibt es ja noch nicht mal...
Diese Netzwerkkarte gibt es ja noch nicht mal ein Jahr.
Die gibt es ja vielleicht in neun Monaten oder so.
Und Realtek unter Linux hat ja einen schlechten Ruf.
Aber müssen wir mal gucken.
Wir müssen mal schauen, wie sich das Ding schlägt.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn gar nichts hilft, dann kaufe ich mir so ein gebrauchtes Ding hier.
Hat Geizhals eigentlich auch gebrauchte Sachen irgendwo drin?
Na ne, na ja doch.
Geht doch eigentlich klar.
Jetzt muss ich mal bei Geizhals was gucken.
Ah doch, Ebay.
Okay, das ist gebrauchtes Zeug.
Jetzt muss ich doch mal bei Geizhals was gucken.
Wenn wir jetzt mal bei Netzwerkkarten hingehen.
Kommen wir jetzt hier zu Netzwerkkarten.
Adapter und Hubs.
Warum zum Teufel steht es unter Adapter und Hubs?
Netzwerk.
Ähm.
Äh.
Bauform PC Express Karte.
So.
Und jetzt.
SFP.
SFP Plus.
Mal gucken, was die günstigste Karte ist.
Die uns Geizhals vorschlägt.
Hä?
Warum taucht da nicht die eine auf hier?
Hä? Wie jetzt?
Okay, machen wir mal PCI Express weg.
Wahrscheinlich, weil da Mist dran steht.
Ja, das ist jetzt ein Kabel. Geil.
Okay, Geizhalsuche ist
Weird Champ.
Warum findet er die jetzt hier nicht?
In günstig?
Weil ich meine, es ist PCI Express.
Wie kaufen jetzt die Festplatten? Na toll.
Achso, ah, muss ich zweimal
SFP Plus vielleicht machen, oder wie?
Gucken wir mal.
Adapters und Hubs.
SFP.
SFP Plus.
Ach nee, ah, Moment mal.
Muss ich, muss ich, muss ich Verbindung
vielleicht gucken?
Ah, hier.
Okay, hier sieht man's.
Okay, die billigste,
die billigste 10-Gegner-Zweck-Karte
ist die, also, ich will ja nicht irgendeine billige,
Ich will eine, die auch ordentliche Virtualisierungsfeatures
unterstützt. Das sieht ganz ehrlich,
das sieht ein bisschen aus wie meine,
nur mit einem anderen
Aufkleber drauf. Chipsatz.
Intel LJ.
Okay, taugt
das Ding.
Kann das
SRIOV?
Okay, ja.
Ja, dann.
Also das ist tatsächlich eine Netzwerkkarte, die könnte man sich geben, ja.
Aber ich werde mir wahrscheinlich eher so eine kaufen, wie ich da gerade gezeigt habe,
wo man weiß, dass die gut sind und auch gut unter Linux funktionieren.
Aber Intel-Sachen funktionieren in der Regel eigentlich immer ganz gut unter Linux.
Ja, dann lieber so ein, weil da weiß man, dass der Linux-Support top ist.
Oh, das ist ein 8-fach Slot
Ja doch, mein Nass
Ich glaub, im Nass, nee, das ist sogar ein 16-fach Slot
Ja
Und man hat 2, warum nicht?
Das ist doch auch nicht verkehrt
Dann hab ich 13 Gig Interfaces, für was auch immer
Wer weiß, was man damit vorhat
Mal gucken
Oh, hier ist abgekackt, was ist da los?
Es expired, schau wieder
Reboot
die Intel.
Du meinst die X520?
Ist Fiber wirklich
spaßig, wenn es nur kurze Strecken sind?
Also bei 10 Gig braucht Fiber
tatsächlich weniger. Aber
es ist jetzt nicht so krass.
Das sind ein paar Watt Unterschied.
2-3 Watt Unterschied oder so.
Lass es mal 3 Watt Unterschied
sein. Das hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Also dafür
Eine Netzwerkkarte kaufen macht eigentlich fast keinen Sinn.
Und wir müssen mal gucken.
Die neuen, hier die Dinger, die sollen auch relativ genügsam sein, was Stromverbrauch angeht.
Ein Vorteil, den ich sehe, bei, naja, Vorteil, weiß nicht, ob das ein Vorteil ist,
bei 10 Gig, bei SR4 Plus Interfaces ist, auf kurzen Strecken,
kann man relativ günstige Direct Attach Kabel verwenden und braucht dann keine Module dafür.
Was es deutlich, deutlich günstiger macht.
Weil mit Modulen lohnt sich das überhaupt nicht.
Dann ist ein Kupferstecker, Kupferkabel einfach viel billiger.
Aber früher war es so, ich weiß nicht wie es jetzt aktuell aussieht bei Netzwerkgeräten, bei Switchen und so.
Also früher war es halt deutlich günstiger, einen Switch mit, sagen wir mal, 12 Port SFP Plus zu bekommen und vielleicht 3, 4 Kupfer Ports als einen, weiß ich nicht, 12 Ports, 24 Ports, was auch immer, 10 Gig, na 24 Ports vielleicht nicht, eher 12 Port Kupfer, 10 Gig.
Das war deutlich günstiger und nachdem damals halt auch das in Kombination so war, man konnte alte Server-Hardware verwenden.
10 Gig, die war sogar noch stromsparender und man konnte günstige Direct-Attach-Kabel verwenden.
War das eigentlich relativ No-Brainer zu sagen, man macht SFP+.
Wie das heutzutage aussieht, gerade MikroTik hat ja richtig gute 10 Gig-Switches mittlerweile.
Moment, wir gucken gleich.
was auch immer da time dauert startest du von 1 oder 2 für dich ich muss nicht upgrade
das problem ist nur okay warum hat das jetzt den blink geöffnet ich starte überhaupt kein
upgrade ich habe schon zehn gig bei mir daheim hier guck da moment windows windows settings
keck wie war das jetzt network internet settings ach das ging ja nicht dahin advanced da fuck
alter ja 10 gig ist das schon hier guck habe ich schon eine ganze weile ist eine uralte
netzwerkkarte eine uralte 10 gig s p plus netzwerkkarte ich habe schon seit 33 rechnern
und ich kaufe mir alle drei bis fünf jahre neuen rechner also kannst du überlegen wie
alt diese letzte karte schon ist aber so lange habe ich die nicht sondern also ich
habe jetzt nicht die komplette lebensdauer dass die netzwerk karte gibt so ich habe aber
mal zehn gig also zehn gig daheim habe ich schon relativ lang war da mal was ich euch zeigen wollte
Also ich hab bei mir...
Zack.
Also ich hab seit Jahren schon...
Warum ist jetzt das zugegangen?
Ich hab seit Jahren schon ES16XG von Ubiquiti.
Das ist kein Unify-Switch.
Das ist ein komplett managet Switch mit Webinterface und allem.
Ohne diesen ganzen Unify-Schrott.
So.
Was kostet der eigentlich mittlerweile?
Alter.
Der ist ja noch viel teurer geworden.
Ich habe damals 500 Euro oder sowas bezahlt für.
Aber es kann sein, dass es den einfach nicht mehr gibt.
Guck mal hier.
Lull.
Es kann sein.
Nee, nee, ich glaube, den gibt es einfach nicht mehr.
Ich glaube, der wird einfach nicht mehr hergestellt.
Kann das sein?
Deswegen ist der so günstig.
Warte mal.
Wir gucken mal, ob es...
Aber es gibt jetzt in es 420 das wir gucken mal ob es für den nachfolger davon gibt das ist ein gig
Edge switch
Das heißt max switch nach meinetwegen
Na sein dass die gar kein 10 gig switch mehr haben hier doch
Er 16 xg das doch meine oder
Da kostet er auch nur 600.
Aber der ist...
Oh, ich glaube, das Ding wird am Ende gestellt.
Ich glaube, das Ding...
Deswegen.
Also, das Ding habe ich schon ewig.
Das gibt es schon ganz lang.
Guck mal hier bei Guides Hals.
Da sieht man ja, seit wann der gelistet ist.
Ein Jahr.
Nee, warte mal.
Wie geht das?
Preisentwicklung öffnen.
Max.
Guck mal hier.
Ich habe den schon 10 Jahre oder so, den Switch.
Nein, ich habe immer noch keine Ahnung vom Battlefield.
Rackman, wie sieht es aus?
Kriegen wir ein paar neue, falls du Bock hast, ein paar neue Pepo-Hintergründe.
Falls du Bock hast und wir gute Ideen haben, was man machen könnte.
Ja, also 10 Jahre habe ich das Ding schon.
guck mal zwischenzeitlich 54 euro aber schön dass du wieder da bist wie gesagt das ding habe ich
schon eine ganze weile und damals wie man hier sieht es war halt einer der besten kombinationen
damals für für ungefähr 500 euro 12 ssfp plus port und 4 das ist also das ist immer noch gut
Das ist immer noch preis-leistungsmäßig, das ist immer noch, wenn er 500 Euro kosten würde, immer noch auch heute kein schlechter 10-Gig-Switch.
So, aber was vielleicht, gut, das Ding ist ja nicht wirklich zu kaufen gerade aktuell.
Was nicht schlecht ist, ist mittlerweile von Mikrotik, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin, die neue Mikrotik-Seite ist absolut shit.
Da findest du nix mehr.
Moment, das ist doch gar nicht die neue
Okay, warte mal
Was auch immer die Leute da bei Mikrotik treiben
Doch, das ist die neue Seite
Doch, das ist die neue
Da finde ich nichts
Ähm
SFP Plus Interfaces
Ja, mindestens 4
So
Das ist der ganz alte
Ähm
Hier, guck mal
Gibt es 16 Stück
16 SFP Plus.
Aber es ist immer noch so, SFP Plus, hier,
den meinte ich, glaube ich, hier.
Das ist eigentlich ein ganz gutes Preis-Leistungs-Ding.
Ähm, 8
SFP Plus Ports.
Leider halt kein Kupfer.
Ja, also das ist immer noch günstiger.
Also, ehrlich gesagt,
wir müssten jetzt mal gucken,
wenn wir hier das mal wegmachen und sagen,
jetzt hier Interfaces.
Äh.
Ich kann hier gar nicht nach.
Ich kann hier
gar nicht suchen nach 10 Gig.
Wer Kupfer will, nimmt halt
ein.
Hä?
10 Gigabit Combo
Interfaces. Ist es das? Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Kann man nicht suchen.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin auch gar nicht sicher, ob die
sowas haben.
Ja, gut.
Was auch immer.
Ja, aber der ist echt,
die Mikrotik-Dinger hier mit SF-Plus
sind echt ganz gut.
Deswegen bin ich fast der Meinung,
also ganz ehrlich,
wenn man nicht bestehende Kabel, die in der Wand liegen, verwenden will, dann ist SFP Plus bei 10 Gig besser.
Das braucht weniger Strom, es gibt mehr Hardware, es gibt vor allem sehr günstige Netzwerkkarten,
dadurch, dass man gebrauchte Server-Hardware kaufen kann, die auch nicht viel Strom braucht.
Es gibt mehr Switches und alles und für kurze Verbindungen, sagen wir jetzt hier vom Rechner zum Switch oder so,
10 Meter
vielleicht.
Oder maximal 15. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange
Direct-Attach-Kabel gehen. Kann man
Direct-Attach-Kabel kaufen.
Das sind dann solche Dinger.
Sowas hier. Guck.
Bastelt auch nicht viel.
Ups.
Solche Kabels oder sowas hier.
Kann man sich dann
Ich würde das gerne öffnen jetzt.
solche Kabel kann man sich dann holen. Da ist ein SFP Plus Stecker dran auf beiden Seiten und intern ist es kein Glasfaser sondern Kupfer.
Aber das ist natürlich nichts wenn man wenn man irgendwie
klassische Twisted Pair Kabel verwenden will die noch in der Wand gelegt sind oder sowas.
Die Dinger sind nicht schlecht, deswegen finde ich sind SFP Plus bei 10 Gig
außer halt dass man möchte schon bestehende kabel benutzen oder halt wirklich muss lange
strecken mit kupferkabel zurücklegen finde ich ist das gar nicht verkehrt
weil ansonsten muss man sich ein sp plus modul kaufen so ein ding hier
das geht aber voll klar vom preis her das geht ja mal voll klar vier stück für 60 euro
und beizweig das geht ja mal voll klar
Übersehe ich da jetzt irgendwas?
Oder ist das wirklich ein gutes Angebot?
Das sind 15 Euro pro Modul.
Das ist preislich echt nicht verkehrt.
Also, man darf nicht vergessen, man braucht zwei.
Ein Modul für die Netzwerkkarte,
ein Modul für den Switch
und dann brauchen wir noch ein Glasfaserkabel.
Weil die nicht sonderlich teuer sind.
Was kosten gerade 8 SFPs?
Du meinst, also ein SFP Plus auf AJ45 Stecker?
Ich glaube, da brauchst du, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es überhaupt ein Rating gibt.
Die sind ein bisschen teurer.
Da habe ich mir vor ein paar Jahren im Angebot einen 5er Pack gekauft.
die, die, ich kann mich
ehrlich gesagt nicht daran erinnern, dass die in irgendeiner Art und Weise
cutrated sind, aber wenn es
10 Gig Module sind, kannst du davon ausgehen, die
funktionieren halt einfach auch mit 10 Gig
egal ob die irgendwie was rated
sind oder nicht
ja, lass uns mal gucken
SFP Plus Aon540
Amazon ist nicht unbedingt das Beste dafür
guck, das, da wird es schon ein bisschen teurer
da, da wird es schon ein bisschen teurer
wie heißt dieser Hersteller nochmal?
Für, da gibt es doch so einen großen
Hersteller.
FS irgendwas.
Ach, die hier, genau.
Ja, genau, genau, genau.
Die habe ich gesucht.
Cookies akzeptieren.
Oh, meine Güte, alter Seide.
Funs halt einfach mal.
Die Seite ist broken.
Na gut, dann gehen wir jetzt nochmal zurück.
Optische Transiever.
Auf.
Wie mich Seiten abhacken, die nicht funktionieren, ey.
Produkte.
Optische, muss ich optische Transiever gucken?
Ich will ja eigentlich nur...
RJ45-Kabels.
10 gig fsp plus ja das sind ich weiß dass die günstig sind
okay whatever ich bin zu was zu finden ja sowas da die sind tatsächlich die
dinger sind nicht so ganz günstig da muss man wirklich ein bisschen gucken
dass man gute Angebote findet.
Also SFP Plus auf R45 kostet ein bisschen was.
Die sind tatsächlich nicht so ganz so...
War das bei Amazon gar nicht mal so schlecht,
was sie im Angebot hatten?
Ja, 37 Euro ist wirklich nicht verkehrt.
Da ist halt das Schöne,
das braucht man nur auf einer Seite,
nämlich dort, wo man am Switch das SFP Plus Modul braucht.
Die Netzwerkkarte hat ja einen R45 Stecker.
Guck mal, hier gibt es sogar zwei Stück.
Zwei Stück für 60 Euro.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Das geht voll klar.
Wobei ich von dem Hersteller, ehrlich gesagt, noch nie was gehört habe.
Quinjek.
Das ist bestimmt China-Chinesen-Zeug, oder?
Guck mal mal.
Quinjek.
Nequini
Jeck
Kleinanzeigen
Das ist doch China-Chinesen-Zeug, oder?
Erzählt mir nix
Oh, es gibt sogar einen Vierer-Pack
Fünfer-Pack
Das kommt eh alles aus der
Ja, das kann durchaus sein, dass es aus der gleichen Fabrik kommt
Chat, Chat, gell
Es ist auch okay
88 Euro für ein Viererpack
Ist
Also, äh
Das ist preislich echt nicht verkehrt
Ja, also es kann sich auch durchaus lohnen
Wenn man nur ein paar
Kupferanschlüsse braucht
kann sich auch durchaus lohnen man kauft sich hier so eine mikro tic kauft hier so ein ding
wie ist dieses ding ich habe schon wieder vertreten checkt
ja wenn man sich so ein ding hier kauft zum beispiel und dann sagt ich brauche doch eh
eh nur ein Kupferstecker oder zwei,
dann kann man da auch ein Modul reinmachen zur Not.
Ist dann wahrscheinlich in der Summe immer noch deutlich günstiger
und ein bisschen stromsprachender,
als wenn man sich einen kompletten A45-Switch kauft.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was da, wo wir gerade dabei sind,
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, was es da für gute Hersteller gibt,
10-Gig-Switche mit hauptsächlich Kupferports.
Können wir mal gucken hier.
Netzwerk.
Netzwerk,
Switches,
und Router.
Guck mal, Switches,
SFP Plus haben wir, RJ45,
allerdings
10 Gig.
Gut, da gibt es nur einen?
Das kann er eigentlich gar nicht.
Oh, Moment, Moment.
fast
ich hab mich ein bisschen verguckt
100k
ja das ist PoE Injectors
das juckt jetzt nicht
noch ein bisschen weiter scrollen
ok guckt
ja also das sind halt so irgendwelche
No Name Dinger wo ich absolut
keine Ahnung hab ob so ein Kram was taugt
oder nicht
Das ist irgendein Outdoor-Mikro-Tick
Outdoor-Switch
Ja, guck
Da kommt schon als erstes
Das Mikro-Tick-Ding
Und das ist aber halt
Das ist halt mit SFB Plus
Das ist nicht mit R45-Stecker
Das hat einen 1-Gig-Kupfer
Da kann man übrigens an der Stelle auch PoE machen
Man muss gar kein Netzteil anschließen
Ja, danach kommen hier
Danach kommen die üblichen Verdächtigen
Äh
Was soll denn das sein?
Mit zwei Pores?
The fuck?
Hä?
das schenke ich nicht ach so in proas so okay das ist für hier kommt internet internet provider
stellt dran aber warum brauche ich so was warum warum brauche ich das den sinn davon verstehe
ich nicht. Kann ich den Stink nochmal 10 GIG nehmen? Okay, keine Ahnung. Dann gibt es hier die
üblichen TP-Link Dinger. Die sind bestimmt unmanaged, keine Ahnung ob das Ding taugt
oder nicht. Unmanaged muss ja nicht schlecht sein. Also für die meisten Leute, die wollen
ja gar nichts großartiges drauf machen. Brauchen auch keine WLANs oder sonst was.
Ja, das ist ja wahrscheinlich dann der erste halbwegs gescheite
Weil das wieder Unify ist
Ich will halt was selbstständiges ohne Controller und Gedöns, ja
Naja, also es ist immer noch so
Anscheinend ist es wirklich besser
Man kauft sich einen SFP Plus Switch
Und für die paar Kupferports, die man braucht, macht man halt sich ein Modul rein
Jetzt wird es langsam auch schon deutlich teurer hier.
Und dann langsam auch nicht mehr stromsparend.
Also man sieht, es gibt kaum gescheite
Switche
mit
Kupferports.
Das heißt, ich bleib dabei.
Wahrscheinlich ist es auch 2026
immer noch am besten. Man kauft sich
einen Switch mit hauptsächlich SFP Plus Ports
und für die paar Kupferports, die man braucht,
macht man Modul rein.
Ja.
So.
Wie bin ich da jetzt eigentlich drauf gekommen?
Keine Ahnung.
Hardcore
Random Sidetracked.
Okay, keine Ahnung, wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin.
Einfach 30 Minuten über Switches und Netzwerk-Krams gelabert.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Ich wollte eigentlich das als Überleitung benutzen, irgendwas.
Ja, mit gestern, aber...
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Schrottnetzwerkkarte.
Wisst ihr was? Wir machen jetzt mal alle Tabs hier zu.
Guck mal, wie viele Tabs ich habe.
Ich habe die Taste durchgedrückt gehalten.
Chipkrise macht Router teurer.
Ist das so?
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Ist ja alles betroffen.
Aber da wollte ich eigentlich nichts zu sagen.
Ich habe mal einen Lüfter getauscht.
bei meinem
den, den ich hier gerade gezeigt habe,
diesen ES16XG.
Da habe ich ein...
Haben wir das nicht sogar...
Sekunde.
Haben wir das nicht sogar im Stream gemacht?
Vor 5 Jahren, guckt mal, wie lange ich den Kram schon hab
Wobei, es wird schon Router-Unboxing, denn es ist was anderes
Drifter
Äh, ne, das sind andere
Wäre nicht in einen Stream gemacht, wo ich
in meinem 16xg
die Lüfter getauscht habe.
Boah, guckt mal.
Alter, hatte ich da noch fette Finger.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Richtig, richtig chonker.
Versus gestern.
Direkt ein Fingervergleich.
Und das Hemd, ja.
Fingervergleich.
Ich glaube, das vielleicht mal ein bisschen gescheite Qualität machen.
Hier, Fingervergleich.
Da ist er. Guck hier.
Können Webseiten heute...
Hier, guck mal.
Viel dünnere Finger jetzt.
Als damals.
Erst mal eine Dauerwerbesendung starten.
Ja, ja gut, da war ich 25 Kilo schwerer.
Weil ich hab mir
für meinen Switch
damit das
funktioniert. Ich hab mir noch so 3D gedruckte
Sachen. Das haben wir,
kann das sein, dass ich irgendwas geleakt hab und das ist
deswegen nicht im
Gigswitch.
Switch.
Was?
Vielleicht habe ich da irgendwas geleakt
und der ist weg.
Pan.
Lüfter.
Vielleicht ist es hier.
Hat irgendjemand den Kram
zufällig hochgeladen?
Lüfter.
Das hat ja tatsächlich ein paar Views
Wetten die Leute Flame?
In den Kommentaren
Dass ich das hier so schepp liegen hab
Und komische Dinger mache
Dinger, Kabel, Trink
Bau bitte nie wieder einen PC
mikro leute mikroresse erinnert ihr euch noch an den aufbau stream mikro mikroresse oder so was
erinnert sich mikroresse
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, das haben wir nicht mehr.
Ich hab mir...
1660 XG 3D Print.
Ich hab mir so...
Genau.
Sowas hier.
Hab ich mir 3D gedruckt.
Genau.
Diese Dinge hab ich mir 3D gedruckt.
Und hab dann einen Noctua-Lüfter dran gemacht.
Also da kann man...
Das Ding ist, der Switch innen drin...
ist ein bisschen zu klein ein bisschen für die standard noktura die kleinen
noktura lüfter und da kann man so einen conversion ding dran machen das hier
packt man hinten an switch dran und hier macht man den macht man die die lüfter
dran und dann passt es
Weiß nicht, ob es da auch einen Guide zu gibt.
Hier.
Ja, genau.
Hier, das habe ich schon vor...
Genau, genau.
So sieht das dann aus.
Und das haben wir, bin ich mir relativ sicher.
Das haben wir zusammen im Stream umgebaut.
Aber irgendwie habe ich das nicht mehr.
Genau, so sieht das dann aus.
Und das ist enorm pock, weil es deutlich leiser ist als die eingebauten Lüfter.
Das läuft auch seit Jahren schon so ohne Probleme.
Ah ja, gut
Dann gucken wir mal
Was auf GitHub so trendet
Das macht schon mittlerweile fast gar keinen Sinn
Mehr zu gucken, was da trendet, weil
Es ist eh nur
Du hast kein eigenes Archiv.
Warum soll ich ein eigenes Archiv haben?
Wir haben das
Wopros.tv Archiv.
So, also, was trennt diese Woche?
Ordentlich.
Was willst du da alles dran anschließen?
Also was wird denn hier getrendet?
AI Hacker!
Ah jetzt geht das auch schon los.
Der AI Hacker.
Oh man.
Eithen Interpreter written in Rust for use by AI.
Aha, AI.
AI.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist, aber ich glaube, es ist nicht AI.
Me, search engine for your docs, knowledge bases, meeting notes, whatever, tracking current.
Was ist denn ein SOTA-Approach?
Written in JavaScript, lass mich raten.
Und vibe-coded.
Ja.
Gut, das ist auch AI.
Also ist alles, es waren wirklich
ausnahmslos alle Trends
diese Woche AI.
okay ganz wichtig was trenne den rust placing die fast kosten tiere
version control klein moment warum braucht ihr wisst ich bin überhaupt kein fan von
irgendwelchen geht plugins oder sonst was der einzige weg geht zu benutzen ist command line
Was soll das sein?
Ein Git-UI.
Okay.
But why?
Also das Einzige, wofür...
Okay, zwei Sachen.
Für zwei Sachen könnten UIs sinnvoll sein.
Das eine sind so History-Visualizations,
dass du so einen Graph hast,
wobei man das tatsächlich auch...
Ja.
auch so machen kann.
Aber das ist natürlich nicht so schön.
Und für Merch-Konflikte,
da mögen manche Leute auch
grafische UIs.
In der IDE,
ich gehe auf die Command Line zum Committen.
Aber selbst fürs
Merchen und Div-Anzeigen
das mache ich tatsächlich auch
Command Line.
Nee, das brauchen wir nicht.
Security Focus Library OS.
Was ist ein Library OS?
Security Focus
Library OS Supporting
Kernel End User Mode.
Ich habe kein
von Microsoft. Okay, geh mal weg.
Microsoft hat mich gestern zu sehr aufgeregt.
check if mail exist check if an email address exist das hatten wir das letzte mal schon da
habe ich mich gefragt wie das funktioniert web applications world one new shell edit
ist es ein neues notepad
Ach nee, es ist ein Command Line Editor.
But why?
Da kann ich, also wenn, wenn ich unter Windows einen CLI Editor verwenden will,
dann einfach nur WIMP.
Beste.
Plano AI.
Okay.
Easy Tier, VPN.
Monitor your Internet Traffic.
Aha.
War ausnahmsweise ein halbwegs interessantes Projekt.
Ah.
Nicht, dass man es wirklich bräuchte, um ehrlich zu sein, aber...
So ein bisschen Statistik über...
Das finde ich...
Das Bug mag ich mir mal.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Mega sinnlos, aber irgendwie ganz cool.
Wobei, so mega sinnlos ist das gar nicht. Da könnte man theoretisch dran sehen,
wenn auf einmal alles nach China geht, dass da irgendwas wohl nicht stimmt.
Okay, das ist tatsächlich mal seit langem ein Projekt bei GitHub Trends, wo ich sagen will,
okay, das finde ich sogar so semi interessant. Ja, Android-Stells.
Universal Android Deploader Next Generation.
Sowas bräuchte man für Windows.
Ich weiß, gibt's.
Aber das taugt mir alles nicht.
Z-Editor Meeting Minutes.
Okay, letzte was wir gucken, gucken wir mal was bei Goat rendet.
Moin Max.
Agentic Workflows, was sonst?
Run Containers, Runtimes on MacOS.
Warum will man Container Runtimes on MacOS?
ist das quasi so eine art docker für für macos oder
okay es ist es ist quasi in docker backend für macos eigentlich ganz cool
auch mac leute brauchen so was auch real time monitor für proxmox docker
Ach, das kenne ich. Das habe ich mir schon mal angeguckt.
Habe ich auch so ehrlich gesagt
den Sinn nicht so ganz erkannt.
Trivi, das kenne ich. Damit kann man irgendwelche
Container-Images scannen.
Botman.
Das trendet?
Moment.
Sorry, ich habe es verwechselt.
Ich habe es verwechselt.
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll.
Ich hab legit kein Blassenschimmer
Was ist das?
Ich hab absolut keine Ahnung, was das sein soll
Webpanel
Ach, ist das sowas wie Cockpit oder sowas?
Oder wie?
Ich weiß auch nicht, wozu man es brauchen sollte, ehrlich gesagt
Keine Ahnung
Ich habe das verwechselt
Und zwar habe ich verwechselt mit S
Mit S2I habe ich das verwechselt
Wollte ich gerade sagen
Das trendet, kann eigentlich nicht sein
Damit kann man
Ehm
Einen Stresstest laufen lassen
Für CPU-Stresstest laufen lassen
Und
ich glaube wenn supported ist auch temperatur und so überwachen und gucken welche frequenz
das hat und so also guck jetzt hier volle pulle acht kurs ausgelastet aber das machen
wir jetzt nicht wir haben sollte das trenden erläutert man hat trendet
nochmal sowas in cloud cost estimated for terraform das sind da tat gar nicht schlecht
Da sagt er dann ungefähr, was sein Terraform-Kram kostet, wenn du es aufbaust.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Downloading von iOS-Apps, Terraform trendet.
Chat, wie sieht es bei euch auf der Arbeit aus, wenn ihr Terraform verwendet?
Verwendet ihr noch Terraform oder seid ihr schon bei OpenTofu?
Oder bleibt ihr auf Terraform?
Bei uns sind sie gerade am überlegen.
Open Source Media Server.
Oh, für die Weebs.
Das müssen wir aufmachen.
Tofu muss ja wegen Lizenz, sonst kannst du nicht mehr upgraden.
Wieso?
Ich habe das nicht so richtig verfolgt.
War das nicht nur, du darfst Terraform
keine Konkurrenz machen?
In der Lizenz?
Das macht doch kaum einer.
Die F-Polumi...
Das würde ich mir wirklich überlegen.
Es ist ganz cool, dass man seine Ressourcen in der Programmiersprache erstellen kann.
Man darf aber trotzdem nicht von ausgehen, dass man dort so viel mehr machen kann.
Ja, weil vieles läuft ja serverseitig.
Da ist egal, was du da für eine tolle Logik bei dir in .NET oder in JavaScript programmierst.
Also das wird auch nicht viel dynamischer nur dadurch dass es in der programmier sprache programmiert werden kann also ich bin blumina
Ich glaube ganz ehrlich ich würde mit dem weiter mit dem standard terraform gehen
Oder open tofu meinetwegen was ja auch in terraform ist. So jetzt haben wir noch was für die weebs was das
App for Anime and Manga.
Ah ja.
Warum braucht man da eine extra App?
Warum tut es da nicht irgendeine andere x-beliebige Streaming-App?
Ach, wahrscheinlich, weil die auch gleich suchen kann.
Tja, Leute.
Oh, wieder was dabei.
Hier ist Fuchs.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Pog.
Chat-IQ steigt.
Ah, ja.
So, mal was trinken.
Ach ja, heute richtig schönes Wetter.
Ich gucke gerade zum ersten Mal aus dem Fenster, keck, wait.
Direkt vom Bett quasi am Computer
und nicht einmal aus dem Fenster geguckt.
Sieht aber kalt draußen aus.
Ich muss mal kurz
auf meinem zweiten Bildschirm schauen.
wie warm es draußen ist.
2,5 Grad geht eigentlich.
Pärst du noch Fahrrad gerade nicht?
Nur bei schönem und
halbwegs warmem Wetter.
Ich fahre nur Fahrrad, wenn ich mit einer kurzen Hose Fahrrad fahren kann.
Weil ich mag die
langen Hosen von den
Fahrradanzug-Dingern.
Mit den, also diese.
Ich mag nur Bip-Shorts. Ich mag keine
Bip-Long-
Hose.
also ich fahre nur fahrrad wenn ich mit kurzen hose fahren kann
uns ist minus 10
so schlimm ist bei uns zum glück nicht wobei es nicht wild wäre es hat er nicht geschneit
So, Chatge, haben wir die Woche sonst noch irgendwas Wichtiges verpasst?
Ich meine jetzt nicht in Politik oder so, da mache ich einen großen Bogen drin.
Vor allem mache ich einen großen Bogen, um irgendwas auf Twitch oder auf Twitter oder sonst wo irgendwie zu sagen.
Weil mittlerweile ist ja so, dass sich jeder über alles auf, also egal was du sagst, es regt sich irgendwie immer auf.
Und da habe ich keinen Bock auf irgendwelche Diskussionen.
Ich meine jetzt so technikmäßig.
Olympia.
Das Einzige, was ich von Olympia mitgekriegt habe, ist...
Das läuft ja noch zwei Wochen, ne?
Zwei Sachen.
Die eine, die da gestürzt ist und mit dem Heli abtransportiert werden muss.
Und der andere, der bei der Abfahrt sich die...
Diese Stange in die Eier gehauen hat, aus Versehen.
Ich glaube, das ist das Einzige, was ich von Olympia mitgekriegt habe.
Ne, ne, ne, du bist outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Das ist in Frankfurt nicht mehr so angesagt.
Da sind jetzt andere Drogen angesagt in Frankfurt.
Man sieht, also Frankfurt Hauptbahnhof, es ist ein anderes Stadtbild wie früher.
Am Hauptbahnhof muss man sagen, ja.
Also am Hauptbahnhof ist es jetzt nicht...
Also du hast immer noch viele Drogenabhängige,
aber die sind nicht mehr so präsent.
Dafür hast du das Gefühl, halb Afrika ist mittlerweile am Hauptbahnhof.
Also du müsstest ja mal rumlaufen.
Du hast das Gefühl, 90% Schwarze stehen da rum.
Was soll ich mit dir da den ganzen Tag machen?
Na, hast du noch fertig geworden?
Naja, wie man es nimmt.
Also ich habe gestern Abend noch off-stream rausbekommen,
warum das mit dem Konfigurieren von der Netzwerkkarte unter Linux
nicht funktioniert hat. Das liegt daran,
weil die Netzwerkkarte keine On-the-Fly
Config unterstützt. Ich habe
noch einen IPXE-ROM geflasht, in der
Hoffnung, er kann nur EFI-PXE booten.
Kann er nicht. Klappt nicht. Habe auch ehrlich gesagt
keinen Bock mehr, mich damit zu beschäftigen.
Und deswegen
lasse ich es jetzt. Ich wollte die Netzwerkkarte
eh wegschmeißen. Was wir gestern noch hingekriegt
haben, da weiß ich nicht, ob du noch dabei warst. Wir haben es geschafft
per Firmware und Flaschen
und Custom-Inni-SAE-UV zu aktivieren.
Das hat geklappt.
Heute machen wir weiter. Wird weiter
am Nass gebastelt. Wahrscheinlich.
Und dann machen wir
das mal mit der Onboard-Netzwerkkarte.
Hat das Ding nur Onboard, nur WiFi?
Nein, nein, nein. Das hat Onboard, eine 10-Gig-Onboard-Netzwerkkarte
und eine
5-Gig-Netzwerkkarte Onboard.
Ich will,
ich wollte ja meine
andere PC-Express-Netzwerkkarte
nur verwenden, weil die SR-EUV kann
und das ein bisschen bessere Performance
für Virtualisierung und Netzwerktraffic
geben würde.
Aber so, ganz ehrlich, das Ding hat genug
Power. Das geht wahrscheinlich
auch alles mit der Onboard-Netzwerkkarte.
Das müssen wir heute mal testen. Ich bin mal gespannt,
wie gut der Treiber ist.
Mal gespannt, wie gut der Treiber
ist für Linux, weil die Netzwerkkarte ist
erst neun Monate
alt oder so was. Oder knapp
ein Jahr alt. Das ist ja
manchmal ein paar Kinderkrankheiten in den
Linux-Treibern noch.
Und nicht nur in den Linux-Treibern.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind, ich muss gerade mal
testen,
Welches NAS hast du?
Ich habe drei NASs hier stehen
Das, was wir gestern ausprobiert haben
Und heute auch ein bisschen mit weiter basteln werden
Bevor wir uns dann die anderen angucken, ist das hier
Das gibt es erst seit einer Woche
Oder zwei Wochen
Das ist eigentlich ein super NAS von der Plattform her
Das ist vom Gesamtkonzept
Ohne, dass wir es bisher ausprobiert haben
Ich sage mal, nur von der Hardware
Ja, warum AI? Keine Ahnung, ja
Blödsinn, Bullshit
von der hardware von der kombination an sachen finde ich ist das das beste nass für so homelab
sachen die ich bis bisher gesehen habe du kriegst dann 88 core reisen 16 138 core reisen mit genug
power du hast fünf einschübe vorne du hast drei interne gut zugängliche wenn es herauszieht nvm
E-Slots. Du hast einen PCI-Express 16er Slot.
Du kannst 96 GB RAM reinmachen
und übrigens, übrigens, hier steht ja nichts von ECC-RAM.
Non-ECC. Ich bin gestern ins BIOS gegangen
und im BIOS steht Enable ECC.
Also es könnte sogar sein, dass das Ding ECC-RAM unterstützt, obwohl
da steht Non-ECC.
ich habe aber kein etc raum das auszuprobieren
was kostet aktuell
es auch ohne es 0 dem etc
das war kurz gucken
Da bist du wahrscheinlich arm davon.
Ähm.
Warte mal.
Warte mal, steht das da?
Äh, das steht da überhaupt nicht.
Wie kommst du da drauf?
Ach, die CPU hat kein ECC-Support.
Zedke.
Warum steht das dann im BIOS drin?
Das macht ja überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Oder meinen die damit
dieses ECC-Light,
was alle DDR5-Rams haben?
Fragt mich jetzt nicht, wie es heißt.
Das könnte natürlich sein.
Okay, ja dann.
Wenn die CPU kein ECC kann,
dann ist das...
geht das nicht.
Aber es interessiert mich trotzdem, was es kostet.
Dann haben wir hier Arbeitsspeicher.
DDR5.
SO.
Warum gibt es da nur zwei?
okay whatever ist das teuer 128 gx 140 euro ok preis pro gig guck mal preis
pro gig das ist das günstigste preis pro gigabyte
ok 48 gig 840 das ist trotzdem teuer als fuck aller gut dass ich noch mal 32 32
gig hier hatte sonst welche arm geworden
295 739 ach du scheiße alter ist das teuer
kann es sein dass sie das einfach nicht mehr los werden gerade bei leute wenn das
wirklich wenn es das hier wirklich gegeben hätte sofort zugeschlagen
Was, ECC-Unterstützung? Nein
Du meinst bei der CPU
War mal Non-ECC
Achso, weil ich
Ich hab nicht ECC gefiltert, ne
Ähm, ich brauch Sideband-ECC
Richtig?
On-Die-ECC bringt ja nix
Sideband ECC
Das gibt es im Endeffekt so gut wie gar nichts zu kaufen, oder?
Moment, was?
Was?
Was kostet das mittlerweile?
Ich habe nach dem teuersten gesucht
Okay
Verkehr drum aber lieferbar
Lieferbar
Aber trotzdem
Von 156
Auf 700
20 alter scheiß ist das teuer
das ist ja brutal
deswegen 690 gb ramper mini forum kosten 1600 148 gekostet 8 wenn du
dir einfach aus dass sie ja moment die verkaufen das ja nicht mehr mit ram
trainer das war auch das gibt es nicht das gibt es nicht mehr mit rahmen trainer
luft
Guck, gibt's nicht mehr mit RAM.
War Amazon? Ja wirklich? Guck mal.
Hier gibt es was
N5, Nass
Pro
Mit
Ist jetzt der RAM dabei
Mit 96 GB RAM
ECC
Ja, Moment
Da habe ich ja wirklich das Nass fast umsonst, wenn ich den RAM ausbaue.
Wait a minute.
Sekunde.
Das sind 32 Gig.
Mal 3?
Ich habe das Nass umsonst?
Ich kriege das Nass umsonst?
Also wenn ich jemanden finde, der das abnimmt, wird der nicht funktionieren.
Aber theoretisch kriegst du das Nass umsonst.
Vom Rampreis her.
Was ist denn hier der Unterschied dazwischen?
Chat, das ist doch dreimal das gleiche, oder?
Ist das hier mit RAM?
Ich check gerade nicht, was der Unterschied ist.
Zwischen den Dingern.
Chat, kennt irgendjemand den Unterschied zwischen den...
Ach hier, okay.
Hier sind 16 Kilogramm dabei.
Derzeit nicht auf Lager.
Okay, whatever.
Also das hier ist das gleiche.
Also 16 Gigs nicht auf Lager.
Ja, ja, man kriegt das für 540 bei denen auf der Seite.
Also preis-leistungsmäßig ist das auch ein super Nass.
Aber ECC-RAM.
Meine Güte.
Warum ist der denn...
Also ich weiß ja, dass RAM teuer geworden ist.
Aber warum ist denn ECC-Rahmen so extrem noch teuer geworden?
Ich meine, wir sind von 150 Euro auf 700 Euro rauf.
Knapp halt bis 2028, ja, gute Nacht, ey.
Es gibt kaum Hersteller.
Aber krass, ey.
Puh.
Echt teuer.
Was ist denn ein IPO?
Börsengang?
Und warum wird...
Du meinst, dann wird es teurer oder billiger?
Und was hat das damit zu tun?
Ah, das ist quasi sowas wie Emission bei uns auf Deutsch.
Dann wird es billiger.
Aha.
Was?
Aber ECC-Raum, das ist ja Wahnsinn.
So.
Okay, lass uns mal gucken,
ob es irgendwelche Videos gibt,
die wir uns zu gemüte führen können hättet ihr den job erraten ok
warum nicht
keine ahnung mich nicht
macht immer gute videos das haben wir denn hier zu bieten obwohl gerade beim thema sind
hauersetup windows von minimal plaud das kommt jetzt nicht da reg ich mich wieder auf
rechenzentrum frankfurt was das deshalb wird vorhin empfohlen keine ahnung ob
Managed WordPress.
Alter.
Aber die schönen...
Mittlerweile... Ich bin ja selten im Rechenzentrum.
Mittlerweile bringe ich oft Dell
und HP durcheinander.
Aber von der Farbe her...
Dell?
Chat, was meint ihr? Dell-Server?
Die alten HP-Dinger, die hatten auch
so eine rötliche Farbe.
Das sind, oder das ist vielleicht Super Mikro
Oder HP
Okay, komm, das gucken wir jetzt
Wenn das in
Wenn das in Frankfurt ist
Vielleicht war ich da sogar schon mal, mal gucken
Okay
Also, Chat sagt
Ich habe eine Theorie, wieso der ECC-RAM mehr gestiegen ist. In der RAM-Krise verzichten die meisten Gamer und Normal-User auf den RAM-Kauf. Unternehmen kaufen oft den hohen Preis. Was denn? Vielleicht, ja. Hast du lüfterlose Nass, die du empfehlen kannst? Warum lüfterlos? Ganz ehrlich, lüfterlos ist eigentlich immer Pains Champ. Besser langsam laufende Lüfter als gar keine Lüfter.
Man hat viel weniger Probleme mit.
Wenn du Lüfter leise stellst und langsam laufen lässt,
hörst du die nicht, auch im Wohnzimmer nicht.
Aber auf jeden Fall besser als lüfterlos.
Ich habe übrigens gestern noch ein bisschen im BIOS rumgefuddelt
von meinem NAS.
Und das ist so gut wie unhörbar,
wenn du die Lüfter runterregelst im BIOS.
Ja, deswegen würde ich fürs Wohnzimmer auch keine Platten einbauen.
sondern
SSDs
es sei denn, man braucht wirklich
richtig viel Speicher
dann kommt man Platten nicht vorbei
also, ich hab die Lüfter
gestern ein bisschen runter geregelt
testweise, das war nahezu unhörbar
ja, immer noch besser als lüfterlos
Verlüfterlos halte ich nichts
So, gucken wir mal
Rechenzentrum Frankfurt
Okay, also Chat, was ist es?
Sieht tatsächlich ein bisschen custom aus
Das könnten, das könnten, das könnten
Von der Farbe würde ich sagen, das ist HP
Aber man sieht es hier nicht
Hey, mein Name ist Markus
Und heute sind wir hier in Frankfurt
An einem unserer Rechenzentrumsstandards
Ist das in Eschborn?
Warte mal.
Und unser Betreiber vor Ort führt uns heute hier rund und wir können alle zuschauen. Los geht's.
Hallo, ich bin der Michael Schinzel, Geschäftsführer von der IP-Projects und wir betreiben an vielen Rechenz...
Wir gucken jetzt mal, wir stalken die jetzt mal kurz ein bisschen.
Ich bin interessiert, welches Standort das ist.
Wie heißen die IP-Projects?
IP-Projects?
Frankfurt Standorte.
Ist bei NTT Eschborn, dann lag ich doch...
Also wenn das wirklich so ist, dann lag ich doch gar nicht so falsch, oder?
Stimmt das, was die da schreiben?
Wo ist die Lindleystraße?
Ne, das ist...
Ach hier!
Ist das Frankfurt?
Das ist Frankfurt Ost!
Hier vorne ist die Hanauer Landstraße.
Ja Moment!
Hier ist doch auch
der Dezix irgendwo.
Hanauer Landstraße.
Wobei der ein bisschen
weiter unten ist, glaube ich.
Der müsste hier irgendwie so sein, glaube ich.
Irgendwo hier so.
Vermutlich.
Interessant.
So gut.
Da haben sie genug gestalkt, weiter geht's.
Das sind nur Standort- und Serversysteme für unsere Kunden.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Also es ist im Endeffekt ein Werbevideo, ne?
Also, jeder Server hat so eine eigene Beschriftung.
Da identifizieren die Mitarbeiter, wo sich das Server befindet.
Also es ist, muss einem klar sein, dass es ein Werbevideo letztendlich, unterm Strich, wie toll sie sind.
Übrigens, Leute, ich wollte schon immer mal Managed WordPress in meinem Stream installieren.
Also falls jemand einen Sponsor-Stream machen wollt, jetzt jemand zuguckt, also ich kann mich kaum zusammenreißen.
Chat, ihr wolltet doch mich bestimmt auch schon immer Managed WordPress installieren sehen, oder?
Ich war noch nie in einer Wüste.
Und jeder Server ist mit Hotplug-SSDs ausgestattet. Hier siehst du auch die Seriennummern bei den jeweiligen Servern.
Heißt das nicht eigentlich Hotswap? Oder ist das egal?
Ich weiß, ich bin pingeliger als der Papst, ey.
...beschriftet sind, damit man eben im Austauschfall die Festplatten eindeutig identifizieren kann.
Du hast hier drüben Status-LEDs, wenn irgendwas kaputt geht oder irgendein Netzteil ausfällt,
hinten siehst du das dann hier vorne auch.
Und jeder Server ist eben über zwei Stromfeeds angebunden und hat immer jeweils zwei Netzwerkanschlüsse.
Und das ist immer so dieses AB-Prinzip, was wir hier leben.
So, also hier haben wir die Rückseite. Sieht ein bisschen wüst aus bei dem Rack.
Naja, also ganz im Ernst, das habe ich schon deutlich schlimmer gesehen.
Das ist nicht so ordentlich, wie man das in manchen anderen Werbevideos sieht,
aber das ist, also, das geht schon klar.
Das geht doch deutlich schlimmer.
Also wir hatten früher eine Netzwerkwand,
dort wo die ganzen Patchpanels oben rauskamen und so,
da konnte man die Tür nicht mehr zumachen vom Schrank.
Weil die Leute Angst hatten, gegen die Tür zu drücken,
also die Kabel waren zu groß, du musstest gegen die Tür drücken,
dass die Kabel reingehen wieder in den Schrank.
und da hat sich keiner mehr getraut, die Tür zuzumachen,
weil er nicht so sehr gegen die Kabel drücken wollte.
Custom-Builds.
Du könntest wirklich recht haben,
weil sonst hättest du eine Blende.
Ja.
Wenn du eine richtige Apparate hast,
deswegen hast du,
wissen wir,
Ach das geht schon.
Da habe ich schon deutlich Schlimmeres gesehen.
Da wird der Labeler ausgepackt.
ist oder irgendwas, dann können wir anhand der Kabelbezeichnungen immer die Ports auch
zuordnen von den Splitsch und dann so ist es hier organisiert.
Und das hier sind Kabel, die direkt vor zum Netzwerk-Rack gehen.
Also diese Kabel hier, das ist die direkte Anbindung.
Zentral an das Netzwerk-Rack vorne, das sieht man, das sind diese OM4-Kabel, die man vorne
sieht.
Das sind die 10 Gigabit-Fallkabel, Glasfaser und Kupfer, jeweils parallel und Kupfer für
IPMI und für die Server, die halt kein 10G brauchen und dergleichen.
Also IPMI ist so ein Managed Interface.
Okay, also für die Zuschauer, ich fasse nochmal zusammen.
Michael hat es gerade erklärt.
Jedes Kabel ist beschriftet.
Sie wissen genau, wenn irgendwo ein Problem ist, wo sie reingreifen müssen, ist das.
Weil du wirst ja auf jeden Fall irgendwelche Experten haben, die sagen, ja, die sollen nicht durchhängen, die Kabel.
Aber das ist ja nicht schlimm.
Who cares?
Das ist vollkommen egal.
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Das ist überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Es ist halt einfach der Beide des Wechs geschuldet.
Das ist dann eher, wenn du es auf Reddit postest, dass dann irgendwelche Wichtigtuer auf Reddit kommen und dann so Dinger schreiben wie, ich wäre schon längst gefeuert worden, würde mein Rack so aussehen oder sowas. Die ganzen Dummschwätze auf Reddit. Aber das ist vollkommen fein, ordentlich und passt alles.
Eine Gradentscheidung, möchte ich mehr Racks in eine Co-Location-Fläche unterbringen oder weniger
Racks, dafür schöner verkabeln, ist dann die Frage, was möchte man am Ende bezahlen. Also hier sehen
wir unser Ersatzteillager in unserem Arcage. Hier haben wir für jede SSD, die wir einsetzen,
für jedes Mainboard, was wir einsetzen, immer ein passendes Ersatzteil auf Lager, damit wir
möglichst schnell und effizient bei einem Defekt von einem Server einen Ausbausch machen können.
Das heißt, insgesamt haben wir...
Was auch ganz praktisch ist, wenn man sowas hat, so einen Technikraum, wo man sich reinsetzen kann mit einem KVM-Switch, also, dass man dann anschließt erst und dann routet das hinter und man hat dann Platz sitzen, weil mitten im Rechenzentrum kann ich euch sagen, aus Erfahrung, ich habe da schon stundenlang im Rechenzentrum gehockt, es ist echt nervig.
nach, also nach so zwei Stunden reicht es dir eigentlich.
Das ist nicht nur die Luft, das ist vor allem auch der Krach.
Das sackt.
Natürlich kann man sich draußen diese Ohrschützer aufziehen
und dann mit seinem klassischen Wagen sich hinter den Server stöpseln,
aber wenn es einen Technikraum gibt, wo es einfach ein bisschen leiser ist
und du in Ruhe was machen kannst, ist es deutlich angenehmer.
Ungefähr 100.000 Euro an Ersatzteilen lagern über alle Standorte hinweg.
damit wir immer für jeden Server das passende Ersatzteil auf Lager haben,
zu den Schnellen auskauscheln.
Sehr gut organisiert, super.
Wie ist das in dem Falle eines Ausfalls von zum Beispiel Hardware,
was weiß ich, fällt ein Netzteil aus?
Wie schnell könnt ihr eingreifen?
Normalerweise, wenn es zu den Geschäftszeiten ist,
innerhalb von einer Viertel bis einer halben Stunde.
Wir haben immer zwei Techniker am Campus, dauerhaft vor Ort,
die dann bei Störungen schnell reagieren können.
Ich würde das echt gerne auch mal wieder machen.
Turnschuh-Admin
ein bisschen im Rechenzentrum rumbasteln.
Ich hab
schon ewig nichts mehr
gemacht.
Weißt du, wie ich früher mit den CDs rüber bin
und Red Hat,
boah, was wird denn das gewesen sein, Red Hat
oder so installiert hab.
Ich weiß noch, damals,
es waren irgendwie 4 CDs oder 4 DVDs
und damals
haben sie sich überlegt,
die Datenbankleute wollten
eine Red Hat Vollinstallation haben.
Vollinstallation. Das heißt,
wenn du dich dann mit dem Monitor an die Datenbankserver
gestopselt hast, hast du auf einmal einen
Gnome Desktop.
Die wollten wirklich Vollinstallation.
Du musstest dem Installer alles anhaken.
Nicht, dass doch irgendwas fehlt oder so.
Kannst du dann nicht in deinem Unternehmen
ein Praktikum machen?
Das Ding ist,
Bei uns ist keiner so oft im Rechenzentrum. Da ist vieles auch outsourced.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer von uns da was macht großartig. Aber das ist eine gute Idee.
Wenn wir den Austausch durchführen können, wenn es am Wochenende ist,
haben wir eine Bereitschaft. Die muss dann erst hinfahren, da kann das natürlich ein
bisschen länger dauern. Aber wir sagen immer so, meistens maximal eine Stunde,
maximal zwei Stunden. Das ist so die Regelzeit, die wir dann für den Austausch benötigen.
Hier, Markus, siehst du unser Out-of-Band-Management. Das bedeutet, jeder Switch von uns ist mit einem Out-of-Band-Konsolenkabel verbunden und auch mit einem Out-of-Band-Management.
Das Ganze läuft komplett autark, unabhängig von unserer sonstigen Netzwerkinfrastruktur und hat den Vorteil, dass wenn wir etwas verkonfigurieren oder irgendwas ausfällt,
dass wir bis auf Konsole remote auf die Switche zugreifen können, um dann zu sehen, was ist das Problem oder die Fehlkonfiguration notwendig zu machen.
Doch, doch, ist bei uns auch so. Es kommt auch kaum einer rein.
Ich war nur einmal bei uns im Rechenzentrum in einem von den kleineren hier vor Ort.
Und da durfte ich ja auch nicht alleine rein. Da musste mich jemand mitnehmen und so.
Das sind dann so die Kernfeatures vom Netzwerk, was wir auch komplett so durchziehen über alle Standorte.
Okay, also für mich als Laie, ihr müsst praktisch in einem Fehlerfall nie vor Ort sein oder fahren.
Ihr könnt es immer von remote machen.
Genau.
Wir können schauen.
Außer,
außer,
es ist halt was kaputt. Da kannst du halt
mit Remote Management nicht machen.
Leute, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das schon mal erzählt habe,
meine, wo ich noch die Ausbildung
gemacht habe, war das, das ist schon eine ganze Weile her,
könnt ihr euch vorstellen.
Meine erste Wartungsarbeit
in Frankfurt im Rechenzentrum
nachts.
Firewall Upgrade
war das. Das lief damals
noch so, das ist eigentlich super
super abenteuerlich.
Du musstest...
Also das waren Firewalls, das waren
ein HE-IBM-Server
mit CF-Karten
drinnen noch.
Kennt die Dinger noch jemand?
CF-Karten.
Quasi die Vorgänger von SD-Karten.
Hier, diese Teile hier.
Compact-Flash-Karten.
Da waren CF-Karten drin
in diesen Servern.
Und ich bin mir nicht mehr
ganz sicher, in welcher Reihenfolge das war.
Also musstest du die Server...
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie wir das gemacht haben.
Ich glaube,
das ging so.
Du musstest die jeweilige Firewall runterfahren.
Das ging.
War hochverfügbar aufgebaut, also du konntest dann die IP
schwenken. Firewall runterfahren.
die CF-Karten wurden vorbereitet
du hast die alte CF-Karte rausgemacht
die neue CF-Karte reingemacht
Server wieder hochgefallen, ich glaube so war das
und wenn du bei diesen Firewalls
was editieren wolltest
im laufenden Betrieb an irgendeiner Config
was ändern, musstest du die
Compact-Flash-Karte auch erstmal Rewrite-Mounten
und dann wieder Read-Only
naja, zumindest
es war relativ sicher, man musste aufmachen
so, und dann habe ich es geschafft
ich bin
am Rack vorbeigelaufen, als wir schon mehr oder weniger
fertig waren. Wir waren zu zweit nachts.
Und da bin ich mit meiner Jacke an irgendeinem Kabel
hängen geblieben und hab das Modul
aus dem Switch gerissen.
Und ich hab mir damals
nix dabei... Naja doch, ich hab mir schon was dabei gedacht.
Aber ich hab gehofft, es macht nix.
Ich hab das dann einfach wieder reingesteckt,
das Modul, und bin weitergelaufen. Hab gehofft,
hoffentlich, hoffentlich
ruft jetzt keiner an und sagt,
es ist was kaputt.
Kam aber nie was.
Hat nie jemand erfahren.
Nix passiert.
War anscheinend hochverfügbar genug.
So, kommen wir weiter.
... Austausch ist vor Ort,
oder wenn es wirklich eine großflächige Netzwerkstörung gibt,
die vielleicht nicht mal in eurer Hand liegt.
alles andere könnt ihr machen, weil ihr hier
angebunden seid.
Wie das hier alles so ankommt,
wir haben immer
bei unseren Co-Location-Flächen immer
ich sag mal in 10er-Rack rein
oder in 7er-Rack rein immer ein zentrales
Netzwerk-Rack. Also das hier ist quasi unser
ein zentrales Netzwerk-Rack.
Also ich hab's bei uns
früher gesehen, da war
es so, es gab
also wenn wir jetzt mal an das
an eines der größeren Sachen
da denkt, also größer ist es
ungefähr auch so groß wie hier, ja,
das ist nicht irgendwie riesig groß gewesen,
da war das so, es gab
immer oben
im Rack, gab es einen Switch
oder zwei
und das ging dann
vor auf ein paar Racks,
das war quasi so ein extra
so ein extra
Würfel im Endeffekt, da standen sich so
ein paar Racks gegenüber
und da kam das dann alles raus und da waren dann auch die ganzen Netzwerk-Sachen drin,
irgendwelche Core-Switches und auch dort, wo dann das Internet rauskam.
...Netzwerk-Rack aus, da binden wir die Glasfaser-Verbindungen zu den Top-of-Rack-Switchen,
also diese RJ45-Kabel, die man hier dann in den Racks sieht, werden alle von hier über Glasfaser von den Core-Switchen verbunden.
oder auch Direktverkabelung von den 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarten.
Also das kommt alles von diesem zentralen Rack, geht über die Trassierungen.
Chat, die sagen ja, sie haben 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarten.
Ob die auch schon mal eine Netzwerkkarte selbst geflasht haben?
Und versucht haben, PXE-Boot zu aktivieren?
Ich gehe davon aus, die haben aber etwas modernere und bessere 10-Geek-Netzwerkkarten als ich.
Und haben keine Probleme damit.
Hat es eigentlich geklappt?
Teilweise.
SR-IOV konnte ich aktivieren mit Custom-INI-File
und Custom-Firmware dann geflasht
PXE-Boot
und UEFI-Boot, damit, das habe ich nicht hingekriegt
ich habe gestern noch Offstream
IPXE geflasht
UEFI, IPXE
ROM
hat aber nichts gebracht, kann trotzdem nichts PXE-Booten
stimmt, was kosten eigentlich aktuell
ich habe ja vorhin geguckt
auf Ebay
nach X520,
aber wie sieht es denn mit X?
Sind auch nicht so viel teurer.
Ganz ehrlich,
kann man sich auch geben.
Die,
was ist eigentlich der Unterschied?
Die sind älter, ne?
Die X520,
die sind einfach älter.
Man sollte X710
wie die Pest meinen.
Aha, warum?
Warte mal auf Englisch.
Warum sollte man das machen?
Classic Reddit-Antwort, ja?
Würde ich jetzt auch so sehen.
hinterher den x520 treiber aus linux wird da nix entfernt
aber ich wie gesagt ich glaube ich kaufe mir doch eh keine netzwerkkarte für das
nass ich benutze einfach die on board 10 gig wenn die halbwegs taucht das werden wir heute
mit daraus probieren wir können hier nochmal eine tür aufmachen wir sehen hier immer das
Links-Rechts-Prinzip, das heißt
links gehen die Kabel weg vom Switch 1,
rechts gehen die Kabel weg vom Switch 2
und da sind dann nochmal farblich getrennte
Kabel, je nachdem
welcher Switch gerade
bei Kabel drin ist.
Okay, ich will jetzt mal
Chat-GPT was
entlocken.
Ich habe eine
Netzwerkkarte
mit
R8177.
Die wird nicht unter
Proxmox.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das so ist.
Ich frage nur
Chat-GPT. Ich will, dass Chat-GPT
sagt, ah,
Classic Proxmox R8127
Problem.
Ist das normal?
Er sagt nicht,
ah, ein Klassiker. Moment, ich will
das dem jetzt entlocken hier.
Ist das
ein Problem-Klassiker?
Ein bekannter Klassiker.
Classic.
Ja, das habe ich
immer mehr oder weniger in den Mund
gelegt. Das ist übrigens Blödsinn. Ich gehe ganz stark
davon aus, dass
Proxmox die erkennen wird,
weil Proxmox hat einen halbwegs aktuellen
Kernel und du brauchst einen Kernel
Ab Version 6.5 oder 6.15 und Proxmox hat 6.17 für die Netzwerkkarte.
Gesamt Rechenzentrum, jedes Werk, jeder Server.
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Die 10 Gig im N5 Pro ist eine Aquantik.
Die 10 Gig im N5 Air ist eine Realtek.
... ist immer redundant ausgelegt.
Hier am Campus, das hast du eben schon gesagt, da kommen zwei Stromtrassen getrennt voneinander an.
Das Netzwerk ist redundant, es kommt hier mehrfach Glasfaser an.
Ja, okay, bla bla bla, weiter.
So ist das hier aufgebaut, genau.
Nice.
Also ich finde, die Racks sind vollkommen in Ordnung und ordentlich.
Bei mir würde es viel schlimmer aussehen.
Also Markus, hier sieht es leider etwas wüster aus als in unseren anderen Cages.
Der Hintergrund ist, dass wir unsere Server auch...
Chat, hatte von euch jemand schon mal die Ehre,
ein Playcenter einbauen zu...
Wobei, die Story habe ich schon 500 Mal erzählt, vergesst.
... selber bauen.
Und wir natürlich auch im Rechenzentrum dann Fläche brauchen, wo wir die Server assemblieren können, wo die Server zusammengebaut werden, getestet werden.
Und wir sind jetzt quasi in unserem zweiten Cage am Standort NTT.
Und hier ist so ein bisschen unsere Werkstatt mit Arbeitstischen und mit Servergehäusern.
Das 5-Tonnen-Playcenter. Naja, gefühlt 5 Tonnen.
Können wir uns auch mal hier drüben die Servergehäuse ein bisschen anschauen.
Das sind jetzt quasi Server, die wir wiederverwerten.
Das Mikrofon von dem übersteuern ein bisschen.
Wir schauen, dass wir eben keine fertigen Systeme von HP oder Dell kaufen, sondern wir schauen, dass wir Supermicro-Gehäuse oder halt...
Ah, Supermicro. Chat, ich lag gar nicht so falsch mit Supermicro-Freund, oder?
...Kaufen, wo wir einbauen können, was wir möchten. Und wenn dann das alte erreicht ist und wir sagen, es rentiert sich nicht mehr, die Server weiter zu vermieten,
dann nehmen wir meistens die Mainboards und die ganzen Komponenten raus, aber verwerten die Gehäuse wieder.
macht ja durchaus Sinn. Ich meine, man darf nicht vergessen,
Hetzner kann ja unter anderem auch nur so günstig sein,
weil die halt, nennen wir es mal,
ja, Consumer-Hardware kann man eigentlich sagen,
quasi bis zum Maximum laufen lassen,
was ihre Hardware angeht.
Ich glaube, die haben auch ein bisschen teurer,
normale Server-Hardware, aber ansonsten,
wir haben ja schon mal ein Video geguckt, wie es bei Hetzner aussieht.
Das sind irgendwelche
Mainboards mit
0815 CPUs
und das ist halt günstig,
hat auch genug Wumms,
wenn da mal ab und zu was verreckt ist, nicht so wild
und das wird dann laufen lassen, bis es
schmilzt quasi.
Bis es sich selbst
zersetzt hat. Ein bisschen mehr
Nachhaltigkeitsgedanke, bevor wir
den ganzen Server wegschmeißen, entsorgen,
lieber Gehäuse, was noch Gutes, wiederverwenden
und dann erneuern, dass es sich wieder rentiert, die auch zu vermieten.
Finde ich wirklich einen guten Ansatz, dass ihr das gemacht habt.
Was mich natürlich interessiert, ihr betreibt ja an vier Standorten in Frankfurt eigene Serverlandschaften.
Warum habt ihr euch genau für diesen Standort?
Naja, okay, das ist jetzt Werbung, das ist jetzt Werbung, das muss man sich nicht angucken.
Wir haben uns damals für den Standort Frankfurt entschieden, weil hier so das Datendrehkreuz ist.
Achso, Standort Frankfurt, ich dachte für diesen Anbieter da, wo sie ihren Kram haben.
da.
Das heißt, jeder, egal wo in Deutschland,
verbindet sich nach Frankfurt. Das stimmt, das ist so.
Und getrieben durch die Banken, die hier ansässig sind,
hat man hier eine sehr gute Internet-Konnektivität.
Köln ist auch
gut, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Ich war noch nie in einem Rechenzentrum in Köln.
Aber Frankfurt ist
der D6, D6 hat den meisten Standort,
aber der Main-Internet-Knotenpunkt in Europa
ist in Frankfurt.
Ja, und
das ist wohl so.
Gute Connection hast du in Frankfurt.
Außer du bist die Telekom und hast keinen Bock dich mit Cloudflare zu einigen.
Ich glaube ich auch, so als Ballungsregion aller Anbindungen in Deutschland,
weil hier die Banken so angesiedelt sind oder woher kam das, das eigentlich Gefühl der Knotenpunkte...
Nürnberg, Nürnberg ist Hetzner, ist in Nürnberg.
Warte mal, Hetzner ist, wie heißt das? Nürnberg und Falkenbach oder so?
Wir haben hier zwei Standorte.
Falkenstein, Falkenstein, habe ich noch nie von gehört vorher.
Internet in Deutschland in Frankfurt ist. Das kommt getrieben durch die Banken und durch die
Börsen, die hier ansässig sind, durch den Handel an den Börsen. Alle brauchen eine kurze Latenz zu
den Börsen, um ihren Echtzeithandel zu betreiben und ja, die ganze Internetbranche hier in
Frankfurt ist quasi mit hauptsächlich getrieben durch die Bankenwirtschaft und daher kommt diese
historische Konnektivität.
Okay. Thema Konnektivität.
Vielleicht kannst du mal ein bisschen was
erzählen, was auch den Standort Frankfurt
insbesondere hier bei NTT, ist ja
doch ein großer Rechenzentrumsstandort, würde ich
jetzt mal so behaupten. Was den
ausmacht in puncto Konnektivität, Strom,
Internetanbindung. Das skippen wir jetzt.
Also beim Thema
Konnektivität.
Moment, ich dachte, wir sehen noch ein bisschen was vom Rechenzentrum.
WTF?
das war wenig wir haben ja auch eigene okay es ist halt was ich gesagt ist halt
ein werbevideo
sind das hier no fucking way microsoft windows 11 notepad moment was notepad
moment seit wann versteht notepad markdown kann notepad markdown
Schnauzebett hat doch keinen Markdown.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Moment.
Mir fällt jetzt gerade zum ersten Mal auf.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Seit wann gibt es denn hier oben dieses Menü?
Moment.
Seit wann kann Notepad denn
Formatierung?
Was ist das denn?
Ja gut, dass es diesen hässlichen
Copilot-Button gibt, das weiß ich.
Seit wann kann das denn?
Und das ist dann unter der Haube Markdown oder was?
gibt es irgendjemand der das wirklich haben wollte in notepad weil wenn ich ein editor
haben will der markt down und alles möglich installiert wo vision studio code ich benutze
der Notepad eh nicht.
Ich benutze Notepad nur hier, um
sowas mal kurz reinzuschreiben hier.
Gleich da oder sowas.
Notepad kann Markdown.
Ich lecke wohl eindeutig
Critical Information. Würdet ihr nicht auch sagen?
Das war mir neu. So.
Und
jetzt
kann wohl irgendwelche Sachen
im Hintergrund ausgeführt werden in Notepad.
Geil.
Ne, das stimmt wohl.
Da habt ihr recht. In der Regel will
eigentlich keiner das, was aktuell
so passiert in Windows.
Ich meine, gestern habe ich mich ja auch
übertrieben aufgeregt.
Markdown.
Tatsächlich?
Und jetzt?
Hä?
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Syntax.
Markdown.
Hä?
Und was genau macht das jetzt?
Schrott, Alter.
Das braucht doch keine Sau.
Die Wurstseinstellung
auch formatet. Ach so.
und ich dachte, der highlightet das dann auch
irgendwie oder sowas.
Das ist dann nicht nur irgendwie ein sinnloses Feature, was
keiner haben wollte, sondern auch noch schlecht.
Gut, wen wundert's?
Wen wundert's bei Microsoft?
Guck mal mal.
Muss ich mir jetzt Gedanken machen, wenn ich die Textdatei öffne in Notepad, dass ich mir irgendwas einfange, oder wie?
Microsoft, Alter.
Attackers to execute local or remote programs.
Okay, heißt, wenn ich das falsche Textdatei in Notepad öffne,
habe ich jetzt irgendeinen Scheiß oder was?
Wahrscheinlich läuft das dann auch noch mit Adminrechten direkt,
weil Microsoft.
By tricking users into clicking specifically crafted Markdown-Links
without displaying any Windows security.
Moment, Moment. Markdown-Links in einem Dokument,
was ich in Notepad geöffnet habe?
Oder Markdown-Links irgendwo, was dann diese Notepad-Sache exploitet?
Security warnings.
Ich verstehe übrigens auch nicht,
warum WordPad removed wurde.
Ich meine, ich war kein
WordPad, großer WordPad User
oder so.
Aber warum?
Es war doch
so perfectly fine dafür.
Ich verstehe
eh nicht, warum es nicht eine Word-Version
mit Windows zusammen gibt.
Irgendwas, was ein bisschen abgespeckt ist.
Aber gut, Microsoft-Logik
muss man nicht verstehen.
... ist ein wirklich cooles Format, das euch ermöglicht, formattierte Texte zu repräsentieren.
Aber die haben WordPad bestimmt nicht removed, weil es Trash war.
Weil wenn Trash removed werden würde aus Windows, dann wären 80% von Windows weg.
... formattierte Texte.
Du sagst also, hey, hier in der unrenderte Version, wir haben einen Level 1-Heading,
und wir können sagen, dass das bedeutet, dass es so groß ist, oder?
Und wenn du es renderst, zeigt es das anstatt dieses.
Es ermöglicht dir, wortlose File zu transportieren, ohne wortlose Größe.
Das ist ein sehr cooles Format.
Das Problem ist, dass wenn man einen externen Ressort innerhalb dieses Files erlaubt,
z.B. einen Link oder ein Bild,
wenn dieser Link zu einem ungesanierten Ort geht, kann es größere Probleme führen.
Die Verletzung, die ich von Pox Online lese, ist, dass es einen unbehandelten Files gibt,
Feil, die wir eigentlich in use that if you click on the link that contains a file,
you are, I will reach out and run that program right now here.
You're like, oh, it's only running a local command.
Exe who cares?
Well, if you for example, would I have a park like this?
We can actually use.
Okay, kann ich da kann ich da auch http mitmachen?
Irgendwelche random Sachen aus dem Internet.
Wetten, Wetten, Microsoft hat dieses Ding wipecoded, dieses Feature.
Ich könnte wetten, Microsoft hat das wipecoded.
... Roll-Click. Before the update that came out, this pop-up that says the link may be unsafe wouldn't have popped up, right? So, you know, there is a user-click involved. So I click on this, but then I do want to highlight, there is a security warning, right? The vulnerability said no security warnings. Well, I'm going to actually run a file that is not signed by Microsoft.
Meine ganz blöde Frage.
Warum
ist es nicht standardmäßig so,
dass
einzig und allein
Weblinks
funktionieren in Markdown?
Wer benutzt Markdown-Links für irgendwas
anderes außer Links zu Webseiten?
Hättet ihr einfach sagen können, es gehen nur Links zu Webseiten?
Fertig?
Das wäre doch das Einfachste gewesen.
Das ist also ursprünglich schon.
Link zu einem Image im Screenshot.
Ja gut, wenn du Bilder embeddest da drin.
Okay, aber das musst du da nicht anklicken,
weil das kann Notepad A nicht anzeigen.
Lokale Dokumente verlinkt doch kein Mensch in Markdown.
Ich gehe davon aus, die haben das Vibe-Code
und da kam irgendein Shit bei raus.
Ich werde die Sicherheitswarnung bekommen, aber letztendlich kann ich die Datei auswählen.
Und, weißt du, das ist nur ich, die Beweise, dass ich tatsächlich
ich habe, die Ausführung ist ein Batch-File.
Das kann ein Exe sein, es kann Python sein, was auch immer.
Okay, ja, aber das ist ja nicht.
Notepad ist ja nicht Obsidian.
Wenn da Weblinks funktionieren, würden standardmäßig mit voll und ganz ausreichen.
Es gibt.
Nun, ich möchte nur bemerken, dass ich denke, der Bug ist nicht so beeindruckend,
wie es die Leute machen können, um es potenziell zu sein, wie du RCE bekommst.
Du musst den User nicht nur downloaden, sondern dann öffnen,
Ja, okay, das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen umständlicher, als ich gedacht habe.
Doch, ich glaube, das wurde vibe-coded.
Ja klar, das kann einem Mensch auch passieren, aber Microsoft hat das bestimmt vibe-coded, das ganze Feature da mit Markdown und allem.
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, ich, sorry, dass ich so auf Pause mache, wisst ihr, was ich mir auch vorstellen kann?
Dass unter der Haube Node.js läuft mit irgendeinem Markdown, mit irgendeiner Markdown-Library.
Microsoft hat ja mittlerweile ein ganz wildes Sammeln zugegeben.
Wusstet ihr, dass das Windows
Wusstet ihr, dass das Windows Startmenü
JavaScript ist?
Das ist eine React-Anwendung
Das Windows Startmenü ist eine React-Anwendung
Das ist kein Witz
Das ist so
Das ist eine React-Anwendung
Also JavaScript-React-Anwendung
Wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich die ganze Taskleiste.
Keine Ahnung, das Startmenü auf jeden Fall.
Warum?
Ja, das weiß ich auch nicht, warum.
Warum kann ich dir nicht beantworten?
Weil irgendeiner das Vibe-Coden hat
bei Microsoft.
Ähm, Tierden?
Ich habe eine Idee, warum das sein könnte.
Ich hatte auch mal sowas.
Kann das sein, dass dein Desktop sehr voll ist?
Sehr viele Icons auf deinem Desktop?
Wie das zusammenhängt, weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich hatte das auch mal.
Da hat mein Startmenü-Button geleckt.
Und der Startmenü-Button hat geleckt, weil mein Desktop voller Icons war.
sobald ich die, mach mal, probier mal
nimm die Icons
und verschieb die einfach mal in den Ordner auf dem Desktop
sodass die nicht mehr auf dem Desktop liegen, nur testweise
und dann klick nochmal in dein Startmenü
und guck ob es jetzt schneller ist
ich hatte genau das gleiche, das war weil mein Desktop zu voll war
warum der Füllstand
meines Desktops
mit Icons irgendwie die Startmenü
öffnen Performance
ähm
beeinflusst, keine Ahnung
das weiß wahrscheinlich nicht mal Microsoft selbst
Das ist nicht neu, das ist nicht etwas, das nur wegen der AI und der Softwikation existiert.
Was ich aber noch bemerken möchte, ist, dass das nicht geschehen würde,
wenn wir nur Notepad verlassen und nicht neue Features dazu inkludieren,
nicht einen Markdown-Renderer machen, nicht neue Features dazu hinzufügen.
Sie haben das sehr gut auf Hacker-News veröffentlicht.
Wir haben offiziell die logische Schlussfolgerung der Feature-Bloat-to-Vulnerability-Pipeline erreicht,
Moment, Moment, Moment, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat, Chat.
Es gibt ein Problem, dass Geräte nach dem Runterfahren wieder hochfahren.
Ach ja, das ist die Geschichte mit Geräte können nicht runtergefahren werden.
Seit ein paar Wochen. Stimmt, habe ich gelesen.
Jaja, stimmt, Geräte können nicht mehr ausgeschaltet werden.
Das ist alles so kaputt.
Es wird echt Zeit, dass ich auch komplett auf Linux switche,
dass ich von meinem Linux und Windows hier Dual-Setup
weggehe auf ein Linux-Only-Setup.
Einziges Problem, was ich habe, sind Games mit Anti-Cheat.
Aber vielleicht löst sich das die nächsten Jahre selbst,
wenn Windows immer beschissener wird und Linux die einzig sinnige Alternative ist,
dass die Leute dann auch sagen, im Zweifelsfall verzichte ich auf Spiele mit Anti-Cheat,
mit Kernlevel Anti-Cheat und dann werden die irgendwann sagen, ja okay,
wir unterstützen das auch, weil die wollen ja ein Kram verkaufen.
Zockst du überhaupt noch ab und zu? Ja klar. Ich bin aber immer noch im dritten Akt,
Expedition 33, hab ich jetzt schon zwei Wochen immer gespielt. Mir fehlen einfach die Games,
ich hab letztens wieder Half-Life 1 durchgespielt.
Random, einfach so.
Weil's mir danach war.
Also ich kann immer noch Spiele sehr enjoyen,
ja, so ist das nicht. Aber
es gibt immer weniger Games, die mich
ansprechen.
Cloud Gaming, hör auf.
Video Sponsor Threatlocker.
Threatlocker is holding, downloaded, knows the baseline.
Threatlocker will deter.
Even right here, go check out.
Thanks again Threatlocker for this.
This is like a very normal mistake to make.
One way that people could have defended.
Ich weiß, dass die Dinger ohne Probleme,
dass das Sachen sind, die gut unter Linux laufen.
Aber ich will ja vielleicht nochmal Battlefield 6 spielen.
Using some sort of ring fencing zero trust technology
to basically just say, hey,
Und ein Problem, was ich habe auf meinem Main-Rechner, ich habe eine Nvidia-Grafikkarte.
Ja, der geht unter Linux, aber gibt ja immer wieder Probleme.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie sieht die Performance von der 4090 aus unter Linux im Vergleich zu Windows?
Vor einem Jahr oder zwei war das so,
dass das teilweise noch 50% langsamer war
als unter Windows. Ich weiß nicht, wie es mittlerweile aussieht.
Ob die ihren Kram auf die Reihe
gekriegt haben.
Deswegen, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube nicht,
dass ich Linux auf meinen Main-Rechner installieren.
Bessit soll ganz gut
sein, ja. Ich hab's noch nie
ausprobiert.
Ganz ehrlich, es wird wahrscheinlich...
Delay ist immer noch da. So, dann klappt
das nicht.
ZG.
Max, erlaubt Battlefield das, wenn du
unsafe Apps aktiviert hast? Boah, ey!
Die können mich mal, wenn ich...
Ich glaube,
es wird darauf rauslaufen, dass ich hier
meinen 8-Core
AMD Ryzen Mini PC,
wo wir letztens im Stream CacheOS
drauf installiert haben, dass ich den
öfters verwenden werde,
anstatt meine VM.
Weil Wayland in der VM
werden wir wahrscheinlich nie ordentlich laufen sehen.
Und dieser Mini-PC ist gar nicht mal so übel.
Wir müssen ein Meme-Tool für Wayland programmieren.
Das wird ätzend, wenn ich Linux verwende.
Das wird wahrscheinlich gar nicht funktionieren,
weil man kann ja nicht so einfach Overlay-Bilder sinnvoll positionieren in Wayland.
Da werde ich durchdrehen.
Weil ich brauche ja hier
meinen Krams hier, sonst
funzt das ja nicht.
Lässt du
CacheOS da drauf? Wahrscheinlich schon, ja.
Was würde ich hier ohne ein paar Overlay-Bildchen
machen?
Ganz ehrlich,
mein Setup finde ich wunderbar, wie es aktuell ist.
Ich bin sehr glücklich mit meinem Linux-Windows
hier Dual-Setup. Das Problem ist
nur, dass X immer weiter
ausgefacet wird und Wayland nie ordentlich
in der VM läuft.
Das ist halt der Sack.
Schade, dass es kein
GPU oder PCI-Path
through unter VM oder unter Windows oder unter Hyper-V
unter Windows 11 gibt.
Wobei, das wird's
auch nicht lösen.
Overlay in OBS
Das bringt ja nix
Ich will ja die Sachen selber sehen
Und außerdem
Hab ich nicht nur Overlay Bildchen
Sondern auch sowas hier
Vibe Cone lassen
Oh ja da kommt schon was ganz tolles raus
Versucht doch eine Avalonia Portierung.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen,
das funktioniert unter Wayland nicht gescheit.
Mit diesen Bildern, Overlayen und so.
Hat bei VirtualBox nicht mal
Paththrough funktioniert.
Nur unter Linux, nie unter Windows.
Guck
Ups, WTF
Gibt's nicht
Gibt's nicht, nur Windows
Avalonia
ging, ja, aber die Frage ist, ob du
transparente Overlays positionieren kannst, wo du
willst und sowas
Das geht nicht unter Windows
Leider
Es geht nicht unter Windows, suckt halt.
Wenn PCI Path Through unter VirtualBox oder Windows funktionieren würde, wäre mega nice.
Ähm, ja.
Das wäre praktisch.
Ja, früher konntest du sagen,
Moment, Notepad will mit dem Internet kommunizieren,
aber irgendwas stimmt da nicht.
Heute? Tja, weißt du nicht. Vielleicht ist es auch ein komischer AI-API-Request.
Das hat doch mit Rust jetzt nichts zu tun.
Die Leute dann immer auf Reddit gleich, mit Rust wäre das nicht passiert.
Ja, ja.
Da kann Rust jetzt nur wirklich nichts dagegen machen.
Rust hilft nicht gegen Dummheit.
Wenn du ein gutes Microslop-Emote kennst, binde ich das ein.
Threat modeling an wehr des renderer lives so that when you click on it you get a call out in an execution
So was the fixes now? Anyway guys. Yeah, I don't know. It's just like
Stop adding features to things that are not broken. Thanks for watching. Check out that gold black and then this new video
Ja
Notepad
Etf
Ich habe jetzt zwei Sachen gelernt.
Erstens, Notepad kann auf einmal Markdown.
Und es ist keine gute Idee gewesen, dass Notepad Markdown kann.
Oh Mann, Alter.
Dieses Betriebssystem ist einfach unusable mittlerweile.
Wenn ich nicht so faul wäre,
oder mich so festgefahren hätte,
wie ich will, dass es funktioniert,
auch mit meinen Overlays und allem Möglichen.
ich glaube
ich glaube so langsam ist der Punkt erreicht
dass ich auch sagen würde ey scheiß drauf
dann spiele ich eben keine Spiele mit Anti-Cheat
und benutze Linux
ich meine ich benutze ja Linux schon jeden Tag
mehrere Stunden aber halt hauptsächlich
in Wine
Das ist eine gute Frage
Ob das dann mit Wayland ordentlich interagiert
Keine Ahnung
Das müsste man in der Tat mal ausprobieren
Ob das unter Wein läuft
Ich hab das blöde Gefühl
Irgendwas wird da nicht richtig funktionieren unter Wein
Aber das ist
WPF und Wine geht nicht.
Toll.
Windows Forms aber.
Tja, das ist aber eine WPF-Anwendung.
Ja, wir müssen das wahrscheinlich
neu programmieren.
Da habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist eine .NET Framework 4.8 Anwendung oder so
Die geht halt einfach
Ja
Okay
Micro-Slop-Emote, zeig mal her
Ne, das ist kein gutes Emote dafür
Richtig uralt .NET Shit
Ne das kriegt auf jeden Fall mal beide nicht
Brauchen wir irgendwas besseres
So was haben wir denn hier sonst noch
Was
Ich bin
Aha.
Das ist mir zu deprimierend.
Das will ich mir jetzt dann angucken.
Aber dann hier.
Apple AirTag 2.
Ich habe
einen Einser.
am Roller
der ist aber nur da
okay das ist tatsächlich ein ganz guter, das machen wir jetzt
Sekunde
Moment, add to
Bobloors
Confirm.
Okay, Chat.
Wir haben ein Microslop-Emote.
Das haben sie sich auch verdient.
Da gibt es aber bestimmt noch bessere.
Da gibt es bestimmt noch bessere Emotes.
Falls wir noch bessere finden, sagt Bescheid.
Okay, Chad.
Nachdem wir heute Mittag weiter mit dem
Nass rumbasteln, mache ich jetzt schon
Schluss, dass ich jetzt was futtern kann.
Und dann bin ich nachher wieder da.
Und heute werden wir mal die
Onboard-Netzwerk-Karte ausprobieren und mal gucken, wie
gut wirklich die Nass-Performance ist und was man
damit alles noch machen kann.
Weil, wenn ich jetzt
drei, vier Stunden oder vier Stunden strebe,
nur mit einer 3-4-Stufe wird mir zu viel.
Nachher.
Ich denke mal so um
14 Uhr.
So in dem Dreh.
Nass. Für welchen Zweck?
Genau dafür.
Chat, wir sehen uns nachher.
Ich mach mich vom Acker.
Bis dann.
See you.